[Music]
magnum p.i returns the CBS on September
24th in Jay Hernandez has taken over the
reins as Magnum and let me just tell you
man CJ is truly embracing the role in
living The Bachelor life style with his
co-stars in Hawaii is there kind of a
boys compound now outside visitors thank
you
we like to call it lambda lambda lambda
you know that's her nice but it's fun
it's fun man
Jay forty and playing Magnum is rooming
in Honolulu with 39 year-old zachery
nitin who plays Rick we're both dads so
we got like the extra room for when the
kids come the kids all left and now it's
gonna be the bachelor pad for a while
and for the first few weeks
it was Steven hill TC Calvin on the show
in that extra room we had the arrow bed
I I went to Costco and got it Steven all
you lose we arrived it was awesome to
walk in and they like oh we already got
here yet even like wanted a little extra
decorative pillows have you guys figured
out your Hawaiian hangout I haven't done
anything because on my weekends um you
know in la de noticias and what have you
that gonna set photo shoot Oh
being a stars so hard no James having a
good time in Hawaii and Magnum is
amazing they have lots of crazy stunts
in it can't wait for it to hit CBS
you